Consequently all goods travelling by
who have been shipped by train had to
be trained shipped at
all. Bris. Conversely.
Goods fruit etc.
. Used to be
a lot of bananas and pineapples and tropical
fruits coming down from queensland and
northern new south wales going to be
toria they also had to be train ship.
My was coming from or
b most of them travelled by train in those
days and they also to be transit and
. Work there was on
a casual basis we used to have
to assemble on the railway
platform in the early hours of the morning
in the winter the frost would be thicker
on the ground and on the rails. And if you
were fortunate enough you'd get an hour
or two's work at i think about one and ten
pounds per hour. At that time so they
were really tough days but you
know we kept going and it was
a good experience. In that way that it
tough and you were up to conditions and
. Also formulated. A lot of ideas
about society in your mind.
If you were going to be any work at
all that you did you lose you do.
Well there was
a limit. I think to which you
could. Go in earnings you
step to make it. And when you presented
yourself for the dole you'd have to make
a declaration or
a statement as to whether you do and
any money through the week. But if the
work was available casual work. Well we
would always prefer to have that then
going down for the dole because as i told
you it was always at the police station.
And you know it's
a certain degree of indignity about lining
up to the local police station and the
local policeman asking for dialogue if
we could do without it. If we could find
jobs here for the harvesting was on
we'd go out into the bush and get
a job. Then when things were really bad and
there was no work at all to be obtained
the dole was the last resort for us. Do
you remember the activities of the dole
inspectors. Well i do to some
extent but they were more
active in the city than they
were in the in the country.
I had no actual experience with them.
I've had reports of and they were
pretty tough prying intruding
sort of blokes that. Always
seemed to have the ject eve of depriving
someone of the dole in his days. I didn't
have an experience i was in the country
towns during all that time. When you get
eunuchs working you trued.
Well it was some time later.
I stopped in or read till about 1940.
I came back to sydney at that time
and my first job back in the trade
was in the randwick tramway
workshops where they'd
convert at the shop to war production
and i start at there again as
a boilermaker and we were making the
platforms for the eighteen pounders £18 guns
and that was my first experience back since
leaving the bridge. Thank you mr jones
room.